thank god you didn't write any willing
jada jokes i did i did you did
well oh that's actually one joke i said
was phil wang this amazing comedian and
you should have him on he's going to be
in texas from london
um
he
uh he he wrote this amazing joke that i
said which was um
that uh
you know oh it's inspiring isn't it um
for so long hollywood's ignored women's
stories but this year we finally got
this a movie about the incredible
williams sisters dad
yeah
that was great but i also
to be honest i did reach out to people i
was going to joke about before and make
sure it was okay with them
because i've been burned too many times
and the camera i didn't want the camera
to cut to somebody looking sad or you
know so i told the williams sisters told
will i told
leo i don't blame you
yeah because people leo was okay with
that that's hysterical yeah so go ahead
[Laughter]
everybody makes fun of him with the
young girl with the young girls
and you know tammy his girlfriend is
like
the [ __ ] like she's actually the coolest
[ __ ] you'll meet and yeah they don't
they don't they don't care
yeah and and the kirsten dunst i did a
bit with kirsten dunst and jesse
plemmons that was completely
orchestrated we talked beforehand you
know the joke was that i was pretending
like i thought she was a seat filler
and uh you know we all worked that out
together
um i got death threats
i got the secret service reached out to
me they were so bad that the secret
service reached out to yeah about that
bit
i'm like oh i think you have the wrong
number this is amy not will like
it must be you must have no you are
getting death threats okay
okay not that i want will to get death
threats but
it just the misogyny is unbelievable and
people you know
wait well i'm not understanding why did
you get death threats
what the what the because they were like
you can't you can't do who do you think
you are to disrespect yourself dance
like that
um
really and the secret service the secret
service the lapd because it was
they were that serious and that many
um
and they called me and they were like uh
you did you make fun of kristen dunst at
the oscars
yes person um we worked that you know
but she was really nice she her and
jesse are the coolest and and she she
even posted like hey i knew about that
bit like because she knew i was getting
death right jesus yeah i know it's
really grisly